what's going on everybody and welcome to
these sixth video in the how to make
your own super computer videos series in
this video what we're going to do now is
we want to copy the image off of our
master SD card the one that we've been
working on so far for node 1 we want to
copy that
to the next SD card so to do that you're
gonna obviously need an SD card reader
so take your SD card and put it into
your SD card reader device whatever it
happens to be mine is my laptop so
that's what I'm using so I'm gonna plug
mine in and to read the actual disk
image into like one image what we're
gonna want is win32 disk imager so go to
google and you can type in win32 disk
imager and we're just can use the
SourceForge here click on that and then
you can download it here I've already
downloaded mine so I'm gonna go ahead
and open mine up but go ahead and click
download and whenever your download it's
done continue with the video so when
you're done and you bring up the program
this is what it looks like here's your
device here and this is the image file
so what we want to do is we want to take
this we want to use the read option
eventually and read from the device to
the image file so what we want to do is
we want to put this image file somewhere
so what I'm gonna go ahead and do is
I've made a file on my desktop called
supercomputer tutorial so I'm gonna open
that up so this is where I want it to go
and here you can put the file name that
you actually want it to be so for now
I'm just gonna call this your master
node and then I'll just put the date for
me it's 218 2014 and so that's the date
february 18th 2014 master node open so
that's where we want the image file to
go now again you want to use the read
option so read data from device if you
hover it says from device to image file
so just don't get those two confused cuz
you don't want to write because this
will write from
the image file to your device basically
so hit read because that's what you want
and now it's gonna go through the
process of reading this you know your SD
card basically to this file now I
recognize I said there wouldn't be much
more waiting but I did tell you guys
that we had to do this so so we are
gonna do this and once you do this
you're gonna insert your next card and
write to it but we will cover that so
for now I'm going to pause this while
this goes on and resume whenever it's
done so you feel free to pause the video
and resume it whenever yours is complete
so when it's all done just hit OK and
now let's go ahead and make sure that it
is indeed there so I'm gonna open up
this file and sure enough there it is
for us now the next thing that you're
gonna want to do is move this file to
your your next SD card so go ahead and
eject your other SD card or your first
SD card so SD card number one take that
out you're all done with that now and
take SD card number two and plug that
into your SD card reader and now what we
want to do is we have this file here
already so that's the file name device
is still the same as in gee you can
check to make sure just I would check to
make sure that that is indeed the SD
card that should be it so again this is
from the device to the image file so we
would this time we want to write data
any image file to the device so this
time hit write writing to a physical
device can corrupt the device target
device got it chickity-check yes and now
it's gonna go ahead and do is write this
file to this device just as a side note
I think I can't Mara I think this one is
actually 16 gigabytes I can't remember
what the size of this one is the first
one was like a micro SD card for 8
gigabytes and I'm pretty sure this
current device is 16 so if you recall
that you know the operating system
already expands to your device just as a
side note this is still gonna be I
believe 8 gigabytes not 16 so you would
kind of like if you if you had a
16-gigabyte one and you expanded that
you wouldn't be able to fit the image
size to your 8 gigabyte or your 2
gigabyte for example so just kind of pay
attention to that so anyways I'm gonna
go ahead and pause this while this is
transferring over I suggest you do the
same alright so once that's done right
successful hit ok now you've got a copy
so what we want to do now is actually
eject this and we're gonna want to put
it into our Raspberry Pi now and
actually you're going to put both your
SD cards into your raspberry PI's and
then boot them up and to access each one
I'm just gonna use SSH and again if your
second Pi is most likely going to have
the same ip address as your first plus
one so mine was 192 168 0 20 my second
PI is most likely 192 168 0 21 again if
you're not positive you can plug in your
monitor again plug in your USB cord put
in the SD card turn that baby on log in
and do ifconfig get the I net address so
what I'm going to go ahead and do is
plug the SD cards into both of my pies
and boot them up so I suggest you do the
same
all right so just again as a side note
take care to look at your boot lights
the first one really ought to boot up
for sure your masternode though your
second pi is the one that may or may not
work correctly if this readwrite process
went well it should work and all the
lights should be MUP pretty much by now
if you had plugged it in before I
started the EP app and so now what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna go ahead and
actually log into both of my pies but
you really just need to use SSH to log
into the master PI but I'm gonna log
into both and you can log into both as
well so because we're going to be doing
some edits and stuff and we'll end up
actually confirming some stuff by
logging into the other PI so that's what
we're gonna be covering in the next
video so hopefully everyone is all set
to this position if your second PI is
not turning on I suggest trying to re
right on to that file or your sd card
again from the image file try to redo
that and if that fails again I would
reformat it and maybe even take another
copy of the first one and try that again
anyway if you have any questions or
comments feel free to leave them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all this board the subscriptions and
until the next video